good afternoon my name is Dale Martin
I am a now an emeritus professor in the
Religious Studies department but for
many years I was on the Terry lectures
committee which is why I am privileged
now to introduce Judith Farquhar this
afternoon
Judith Barker is the max poleski
professor emeritus and the department of
anthropology at the university of
chicago and the faculty director at the
university of chicago center in beijing
her most recent book ten thousand things
nurturing life in contemporary beijing
published in 2012 provides an
anthropological account of how
contemporary Chinese in Beijing manage
and cultivate their own well-being
besides being an expert in traditional
Chinese medicine its history and current
practices professor Farquhar is a
sophisticated theorist and after hearing
her first two lectures I would say also
a philosopher she might not like that
the tairy lectures are intended to focus
on issues of science and religion with
both sides of that dualism broadly
interpreted science including all kinds
of study of nature and reality
especially including the social sciences
and religion interpreted as including
all kinds of understandings of ethics
meaningful behavior value and values in
her first lecture the myriad things
professor Farquhar noted that science
and religion are not so different
pragmatically and Farquhar identifies
herself philosophically and
mythologically as a pragmatist
there's no essential difference between
science and religion all of us accept
and work with the findings of science as
they have been told to us by practicing
scientists few of us have the math to
check their work ourselves so especially
in today's world of quantum mechanics
cosmology and theoretical physics
science is also taken on faith by at
least most of us for Wars first lecture
introduced us to traditional Chinese
medicine including its important
developments in the night in the 1950s
and fir
in its revival in the 1980s she forced
us to consider what we are doing when we
take something anything to be a thing as
a scholar of Religious Studies I was
amazed at how much her first lecture was
about metaphysics and ontology what kind
of thing is a disease understood in
different systems what are we trying to
avoid when we hesitate to call a
phenomenon a thing in her second lecture
yesterday discerning patterns or thought
professor Farquhar walked us through the
actual clinical methods of the
practitioners of traditional Chinese
medicine medicine we learned is thought
medicine is the disciplined limited
practice of discerning patterns medicine
boils down to nothing but thinking via
four examinations looking listening and
smelling which is one category asking
examination and palpating broadly
understood to include all kinds of touch
and observation practitioners look for
patterns of manifestations images and
figuring out how to read them if the
first lecture was very philosophical and
theoretical which it was the second was
empirical and detailed we all Accord to
her third and last of these teri
lectures today humanity as root or
action I'm glad I looked up I didn't
have that last part and I can't close
today without noting that I have known
and loved Judy Farquhar for almost 30
years and I can say that because her
husband went back to Chicago over the
weekend so don't tell Jim I said that
because he'd probably beat me up so join
me in welcoming Judy
he'd just be jealous he wants you to
lock him justice I'd love him to you
thank you so much Dale and it's so nice
to hear what I said the last two times
because I tend to forget okay
I'm hoping with this third lecture on
reality recent and action through an
engagement with Chinese medicine can
with an even more thorough attention to
practice shine a new light on some
points I made in the first two lectures
I want to show how the imperative of
taking therapeutic action is essential
to the salient existence of clinical
things and intrinsic to medical
reasoning it is not trivial to point out
the inseparability of reality and reason
from action
partly because Anglophone common sense
still maintains a deep difference
between thing and thought we tend to see
natural objects as external to
consciousness as solely and simply
material as discrete objects like those
floating anatomical organs I showed you
in the first lecture and the knowledge
so crucial to thinking is too often
treated as the cognitive contents of
minds like buckets this is Karl poppers
image buckets that collect a jumble of
representations and concepts that more
or less truly reflect an empirical world
because I want to defeat this bucket
theory of mind as popper did and
challenge the correspondence theory of
truth today I want to be even more
pointedly pragmatist about questions of
truth than I was yesterday the
pragmatist asks how the imaginable
consequences of any fact being true
suffused pervade or contingently
constitute both our perceptions of real
things and our conceptions of what is
going on the pragmatist pragmatist
cannot see or think aimlessly the
chinese doctor does not know pure
contemplation of an external world
practical people they do not waste time
with things and thoughts that are purely
useless but this means of course
that they and I find it hard to identify
anything real that is purely useless
continuing to think about actual
patterns of practice then I will
eventually open these lectures to some
ethical and even political concerns that
modern Chinese medical practitioners and
perhaps all medical practitioners cannot
evade because they must act and because
they must consider the consequences of
their actions the epigraph for this
lecture about crossing rivers by feeling
for stones is my favorite image of how
practical medicine and much else should
proceed but neither the Chinese nor the
English translation says it all when
this proverb is read narrowly when
misses the feeling of bare feet groping
along the bottom of a rushing stream its
waters obscuring to our sight the
contours of the unyielding things those
stones that demands such nervous care
from us perhaps you're not stopping to
imagine the dangers of this operation
which negotiates slippery surfaces and
possibly treacherous currents most
streams would moreover seem to afford
many crossing points at first when
you're standing on the bank looking at
the water's surface
but once you've tentatively taken a step
or two into the water your options for
ways of reporting the stream are
progressively reduced no amount of good
thinking or advanced planning is going
to get you safely across the stream with
your eyes wide open but still half blind
you have to commit yourself to a course
of action one step at a time and as you
go you have to live with the
consequences like any good Chinese
proverb this one can be unfolded even
further and I might return to it in what
follows but I want to really begin this
lecture with a few basic observations
about what Chinese medicine is like when
it's at home in modern clinics in China
I will describe and analyze some
observable characteristics of Chinese
medical practice in today's China but
not comprehensively after all
traditional Chinese medicine or TCM is
an immense and complex landscape of
contending a
pinions changing institutions and
diverse forms of work today I'm drawing
on a particular clinical approach to TCM
healthcare delivery that is rather
well-established in China today and most
often encountered in hospitals and
clinics both public and private I won't
be touching on the practice of
acupuncture and massage which is a pity
because they're very interesting instead
I'm letting herbal medicines service an
exemplar of things thought and action
I'm leading you along this route across
the stony stream bed of an important
kind of Chinese medicine in order to
explore an allegory for a philosophy of
action drawn from Chinese medicine so
let's see how it works so we need to get
our feet wet in the flow of practice the
clinical encounter of Chinese medicine
is most often conducted by fully clothed
people with minimal technology usually
the doctor and patient face each other
seated at the corner of a desk or table
where the doctor can reach the patient's
wrist in order to take her pulse this
arrangement of bodies expresses the
fundamental composition of the clinical
encounter Wow yes
which in Chinese is referred to as con
Bing looking at illness doctor and
patient look at illness together equals
in their orientation to the problem but
far from identical in their expertise
several of these images are from urban
clinics when you arrive at such a
well-organized Hospital you have to
register for the clinic of a particular
doctor if you don't already know who you
want to see or if you're not sure who is
on duty in clinic today you can study
the picture display of practitioners
specialties and clinic days and hours
that is posted inside the front door
then you register at the registration
desk for that doctor and that clinic in
the 1980s when I was spending a lot of
time in a Guangzhou Hospital at Chinese
medicine registration meant that you
received a tiny slip of paper with your
unique number for the day on it and
carried it with your personal case
record booklet to the clinic you chose
in those days patients or their work
units managed everybody's case records
they were not hidden away in hospital
basements or come
tutors barging right into your doctor's
busy room where there are already
patients family members students and
interns taking up all the seats you
leave your registration number on his
desk or give it to an assistant then you
wait probably feeling miserable because
after all you are a sick person until
your number is called from inside the
room then comes the key gesture around
which i think so much turns the chinese
medical doctor takes your registration
number and pastes it to a prescription
form think about the meaning of this
gesture not a word has passed between
you and the doctor he is barely even
glanced up from finishing the
prescription he's written for the last
patient and yet he knows and you know
that something will be done everyone
expects an action to result from this
episode of looking at illness together
at least in the form of an herbal
medicine prescription neither of you is
waiting upon lab results to confirm that
you are ill there's no danger that you
will be told to go home and suck it up
it's all in your head in the Chinese
medical clinic there are no purely
imaginary illnesses both you and your
doctor presume that everything is not
right with you and both of you are
confident that there will be something
in the vast Chinese pharmacopoeia that
can address the problem even if you're
only feeling just a bit subnormal and
this is a thing by the way it's called
yo Chan Khong you both know there are
powers that can be deployed by the
doctor to tune you up and make
everything work a little better okay so
now you know you're going to go away
with some medicine for your discomforts
though neither you know the doctor knows
for sure whether it will work as hoped
or whether it will work immediately
in modern clinics the doctor prepares to
formulate an intervention by looking
listening smelling asking and palpating
as I discussed in my last lecture recall
that you've carried your case record
booklet into the clinic with you you
turn it over to your doctor or to his
intern and someone finds a blank page to
record the information gathered through
the four examinations the various
observed and reported illness
manifestations appear as a simple
list with a date and a signature from
the doctor when in my last lecture I
talked about the four examinations and
the kind of information they collect I
wanted to emphasize the qualities and
images on the surface of things which
are perceptible by the doctor looking at
illness manifestations but take a closer
look at the slide at this slide which we
also had last time these signs and
symptoms are not just images or
manifestations when negative attitudes
no appetite greenish tone coding or a
thin taut pulse all turn-up is part of
the same unstructured list they provide
more information to read than any direct
examination of the surface of bodies
could what broad aspect of reality does
the four examinations method actually
examine I propose influenced by my
teachers in the institutions of Chinese
medicine and by William James the
radical empiricist that this category is
experience these symptoms are
experiences of illness disorder of
various sizes and shapes perhaps then
the patient may report anxiety and
excessive dreams or he notes that he had
a bad flu before developing arthritic
pains or she confides that she works in
a salon restaurant kitchen and is
constantly breathing the odors of spicy
food perhaps he confesses to feeling a
heaviness and pressure in his chest or
she says she feels a lumpy obstacle deep
in her throat all these are very
significant contributions to the
thinking of the Chinese medical doctor
as he engages in what I call Cognos Asst
of the illness pattern he does not doubt
the patient's account nor does he worry
that the patient might be deceiving
himself with a merely plausible myth of
affliction those facts reported by the
patient's learned from the asking
examination are not less or more
meaningful than the pulse and tongue
images that can be observed in the
present or the immediately perceptible
skin rash stiff movements or greenish
skin that might be seen around the eyes
the presumption is that the patient is
the expert of her own experience and
ultimately this is a pragmatic
empiricist point experience is all we
have to go
experience I hasten to insist is not
confined to fortress-like individuals
but is most often fluently shared in
collectives of many kinds in some
symptomatic experiences are written down
in your case record booklet and become
the trusted factual things with which
therapeutic action must deal with this
point perhaps you'll hear my implicit
contrasts with some situations in our
North American biomedical clinics at
least as these are perceived from the
patient's point of view when I report to
my excellent and tactful primary care
physician in Chicago that the sleeping
pills I was taken to control jetlag
produced panic attacks she is kind but
she is not interested this kind of
symptom is my concern not hers she
doesn't know what to do with panic as a
sign of organic disorder a Chinese
medicine doctor does but how well bear
in mind that any experience can count my
TCM doctor conceives of the accumulated
recorded knowledge of East Asia's
several hundred several thousand year
history of medical practice as a record
of experiences the archive is full of
doctors and patients experiences arising
from illness consultations these are
experiences of looking at illness
together these recorded experiences
you're not just miscellany dismissible
like my drug related panic attack rather
they provide useful information because
they have been grouped into standard
traditional correlations in my last
lecture I showed a series of slides with
examples of the standard classifications
of experienced symptoms with six of the
eight rubrics here they are again just
to remind you to give you an idea the
first pair is cool and warm and you see
there's a long list of symptoms that
might be classified as either cool or
warm the second pair is shallow and deep
similar list of symptoms and the third
pair is depletion and repletion which is
a good deal more complicated but
nevertheless it's still a duality and
the fourth couple of the eight rubrics
Ian and Yong is even more complicated
these systems are much more extensive
than these slides can show but I hope
these lists give you a feel for the
vastness
of TCM systematic information now I
could use the more elaborate correlation
tables from which I took these slides to
discern the patterns that afflicted me
when I was having those sleeping pill
induced panic attacks agitation pressure
in the chest shortness of breath heart
visceral system tension and various more
intimate bodily symptoms could all have
been classified and correlated and I
could have come up with a preliminary
name for my pattern here's my guest long
after the fact warm repletion of heart
system qi at depth this sounds like a
strongly young disorder and somehow when
I'm feeling agitated in this way I know
that and my Chinese doctor can know that
too or he can disagree with my
rough-and-ready correlations to offer
more nuanced and possibly contradictory
picture of what's going on in either
case both of us doctor and patient have
to take a long list of experiences into
account in order to properly classify
them and note these are not just my
experiences at issue my symptoms have to
be understood in light of the systematic
arrangement of everybody's experiences
which tradition has given us once
classified and correlated as I will soon
show my experiences my signs and
symptoms and especially my patterns of
disorder my jung-ho become actionable
and that is the whole point of pulling
off these correlations to make it
possible to intervene in a specific way
for a specific disorder I'll return to
this question of how personal
experiences of illness are linked to the
long history of collective medical
experience the first I want to leave I
don't want to leave our TCM clinics
without finishing the story of what
happens in them as the doctor is
collecting all your experiences of
discomfort while your signs and symptoms
are being noted down in a list in your
case record booklet analysis is already
underway the doctor is for example
classifying your signs under the four
rubrics according to the traditional
correlations I just listed the other
analytic system she has available I
highlight a few in this slide also
classify and correlate experiences in
order to characterize the pattern
abstractly thus my doctor might arrive
at a pattern name like the one I
speculatively proposed above warm
repletion of heart system chief
affecting the protective yin sector at
death in many clinics a pattern name
like this even if it is shorter and less
clumsy is not written in the case record
booklet even more interesting many
doctors don't bother to write down the
treatment principles guiding their
choice of drug formula the moment of
determining therapy in this practical
logical formation quite often goes
without saying perhaps keeping some key
strategic insights off the record is a
form of resistance to biomechanical
diagnosed diagnostic and technical
regimes or rejection of the clinical
protocol in modern China but when I ask
doctors to explain to me what seemed
like a crashing silence about strategies
for therapeutic action they patiently
explained that these abstractions are
not needed everything the experienced
clinician needs to know about the
patient and his disorder and about any
previous clinicians interpretation of
that situation can be understood from a
reading of the series of herbal
prescriptions many times I've seen
doctors and even TCM amateurs gaze
appreciatively on a prescription written
in a previous clinical encounter they
might say oh are you still constipated
constipated or clearly the weather was
getting to you then let's figure out how
to reduce your body's humidity I want to
emphasize then the Chinese medical
herbal prescription is at the heart of
the field for insiders to the field it
embodies the central form of action and
it is a key expression of its medical
author's expertise the prescription
consists of the names of six to 20
natural medicines vegetable mineral a
few animal processed in various ways
carefully quantified in grams there are
many classic prescriptions and most of
the time any actual prescription is
built on the foundation of a well known
formula this formula is not only written
on a prescription form it should also be
recorded in the patient's personal
booklet that way the next time she sees
the doctor he'll be able to know without
being told they
except by looking at the list of herbs
what was happening before and what was
done about it
our clinician then concludes the
clinical encounter by writing an herbal
prescription on a form with the
patient's registration number attached
for the use of the pharmacy and the
hospital cashier as their doctor is
writing she thinks back not only to her
methods of pattern discernment but also
recalls the presenting symptoms the
doctor might add a medicine for insomnia
or constipation to a formula
traditionally intended mainly to improve
let's say the dredging and draining
function of the liver system speaking as
a patient we can see this perceiving and
thinking at work as the doctor acts to
intervene with medicines she appears to
concentrate as she is designing and
quantifying the formula but she
sometimes stops and double-checks
something did you say you had trouble
falling asleep do you wake up with a
headache the designer of a prescription
not only needs to make sure that the
various drugs cooperate well among
themselves to advance a complex
therapeutic agenda he wants to address
even the peripheries and surfaces of
your pattern by customizing your drug
cocktail reflecting on the practical
form of the clinical encounter of
Chinese medicine let me make two other
points before returning to more general
questions of action first we might note
how satisfying it is to the patient to
me with my jetlag induced miseries to
respond to my TCM doctors curiosity
about so many aspects of my personal
bodily life he's not trying to reach a
reductive diagnosis that authorizes him
to ignore my miscellaneous subjective
discomforts rather he's trying to figure
out how to keep all our experiences in
play together to understand a complex
pattern or grain or currents and Eddie's
of this moment in my embodied life this
is especially evident in the writing
sometimes in beautiful and much admired
calligraphy of an herbal prescription
and the botanical and pharmacological
complexity of any herbal prescription is
deeply appreciated by doctors and
patients
alike there's an intimacy to this
clinical relationship which by the way
really ought to extend over multiple
visits to look at El Nasir Chinese
doctor and this is the second
observation I want to make about
clinical action as I described it this
closeness this sense of partnership is
most clearly and practically expressed
with the TCM clinical scene a quinone of
feeling the pulse I mentioned in the
second lecture talking about the four
examinations that in theory there are 18
possible positions at the wrists where
28 different pulse qualities might be
discovered
no doctors that I know of ever attend to
so many pulse qualities but it is
interesting that they evaluate the pulse
not just for speed checking pulses
against a wristwatch but they compare my
pulsing with the pace and rhythm of
their own breathing the doctors own body
is the criterion of health or illness
and of course pulse takers are
interested in so much more than the rate
of pulsation pulse qualities are
sometimes expressed poetically taut like
a bowstring rough and catching like
sandpapering against the grain rolling
like a pearl in a plate skipping like a
flat stone across the water thread like
flooding in the feeling of the pulses
there is a kind of Chi exchange going on
for those few minutes that the risks are
being felt there is no problematic
doctor-patient relationship no question
of a hard to attain intersubjectivity
the flow and transformations of Chi like
the living transformations of the great
way are a shared experience not a
remotely perceived image William James
defining experience had an eerily
convergent philosophical point to make
if we start with the presupposition that
there is only one primal stuff or
material in the world a stuff of which
everything is composed surely he's
talking about Chi and if we call that
stuff pure experience then knowing can
easily be explained as a particular sort
of relation towards one another into
which portions of pure experience may
enter the relation itself is a part of
pure experience
one of its terms becomes the subject or
bearer of the knowledge the knower the
other becomes the object known this will
need much explanation before it can be
understood indeed it will if this was
written in 1907 and I'm not sure too
many people have noticed it since but
there's no time to recapitulate a jamesy
and fewer experience today rather I'm
trying to work my way towards
characterizing action in a Chinese
medical world populated with
transforming things and thoughts
butchy that primal stuff that is at the
very same time infinitely plural Marriot
in its forms and ever active this is not
a bad thing to think with when we're
trying to focus on action and I will
eventually return to Qi at this point we
need to be reminded about the nature and
centrality of practice by some Chinese
thinkers we've had dong Xiao ping
advising us to find our way across
rivers by feeling the stones we have had
implicitly a Maoist practice
epistemology at work in my frequent
distinguishing between perception as in
the four examinations and conception as
in the methods of discerning patterns
and one of our ancient texts the one I
both quoted and paraphrased at the end
of lecture two also gives us insights
into practical action so let's remind
ourselves of that text this fifth
summary summary summation says a great
deal about action as engaged practice in
a fluidly transforming universe and it
is quite consistent with Dajjal pings
little dictum about crossing rivers
feeling for stones in a way but this
assertion that medicine is thought does
not read like a modern text one of the
most puzzling bits in this passage is
medicines acting on the pattern like a
god I experimented with other
translations of this phrase you may
recall that in my paraphrase at the end
of the last lecture I rendered it as
magically effective but what the Chinese
actually says is like a god how does a
God act then a while back I pointed out
that standard practice in the Chinese
medical clinic makes a standard process
promise your ailment will be recognised
and our medicines
respond with a treatment this promise is
only implicit in clinic practice but it
is eerily similar to some explicit
promises made by gods this is the
entrance to the great hero palace in
Shanxi who knows in temples all over
China there are banners and placards
like this one which on the handmade
banner says yo Cho being or to your
petition we must respond I always
thought this was an odd promise to make
how can either petitioner or deity be so
sure that every need will be met in
response to prayer and ritual gifting
can doctors be just as sure of the
magical effectiveness of their medicines
well they're not of course all clinical
work is riddled with uncertainties as
medical sociologists have often shown
but Chinese healers do tend to think of
the activity of drugs and gods in more
or less the same way gods have powers
though Chinese gods are never on nough
'putin t' and natural medicines have
powers powers that can be relied upon in
a relationship of engagement and
participation as our text says on
occasions when people seek a solution to
complex patterns of disorder let's look
at another aspect of the Chinese passage
one thing with which the knower engages
is with the sorts of things it appears
that all the modern classification work
that as we've seen groups medical
experience and two correlated rubric
systems and sectors is not just modern
even in the fifth century when this
quote was first written it was clear
that illness phenomena could not be
engaged with engaged with as a pure
infinity of boundless myriad experience
of the transformations and changes is
far from being just one damn thing after
another for the medical practitioner no
medical experts know that is necessary
to work with the sorts to sort things
out symptoms classifiable is warm or
cool shallow or deep more heart than
liver more young than Yin are not all of
the same value and treating the illness
they expressed does not call for just
any powerful drug drugs to come in
towards the vast materia medica of
Chinese medicine identifies each of its
drugs with a character allowing them to
be classified as for example cooling or
warming as belonging to one of several
efficacious flavors or is having an
affinity with one or another visceral
system the correlations of pathological
symptoms have their parallel in the
correlations of the materia medica hence
the master statement in our 5th century
text doctors illuminate the pattern of
illness and medicines act on it like a
god this is what medicine does drugs
known to be responsive like gods after
hundreds of years of attentive use and
careful record-keeping are brought to
bear on a complex Lee specific disorder
that has been expertly characterized in
the clinical encounter through
correlating and classifying although the
rubrics and relationships used for the
patterns are not the same as the rubrics
and relationships used to characterize
drugs these two groups of sorts have a
closed logical and characterological
kinship the parent this parallel sorting
allows natural things to be applied from
the outside where they respond minutely
subtly with fine tuning to a well
characterized inner disorder as our text
more or less says sorting things out
properly and making things happen as
desired in any given clinical encounter
of Chinese medicine is not easy when you
consider the ever presence of a huge
archive of case records herbal
prescriptions debates experiences
experiments doubts and worries appealing
mythologies and acts of faith medicine
and China comes from the fabled 2,000
years of practical experience in the
laboring people's battles against
disease as the Maoists used to say
discerning patterns and determining
therapy is the work of seasoned and
well-read experts these experts are
scholarly and scientific yes but they
are first and foremost clinicians the
potential problems that present to the
doctor are very numerous the analytical
resources she can draw on are
very rich in a world of pure experience
tradition cannot dictate binding
protocols or provide standard rule books
for Responsible action maybe this is why
the text we've been reading emphasizes
the transformations and the changes even
as it addresses limits to medical
perception at the same time as this
early author insists on engagement with
the class of of the Tauri sorts it also
praises the minut participation of the
doctor and his medicines with the
transformations and the changes
everything is always changing into
something else
categories overlap systems for sorting
are only heuristics and even they change
and these conditions the landscape
navigated by the Chinese doctor looks a
lot like the quasi chaos of the radical
empiricists of pure experience but
nobody can do anything in a world in
which everything is everything
fortunately doctors writers and
educators in the world of Chinese
medicine have some rules of thumb that
respond to the infinite Nisour the non
finiteness of the transformations and
the changes they tell their students and
interns and they told me to control
illness one must seek out the root
sometimes I translate this phrase as one
must race down to the root because this
setting of priorities is not an easy
process it involves a lot of groping
around in getting your hands dirty as
you've distinguished between what is
growing and what is dying away or as you
find or infer a taproot while trying not
to damage collateral radicals in Chinese
medical education I don't think anyone
ever really explains to the budding
clinician how to pull off this
identification of the root as the
practitioner correlates and infers his
way into the darkness of pathological
process and tries to distinguish between
pathological sources and symptomatic
manifestations even when you have a
hypothesis about the most central source
of the many symptoms you proceed how do
you know you've found the route how do
you know that you're not just imagining
your wait is implausible but ultimately
bogus process that will
be in the end successfully actionable
well this is one reason medical
education is an extended process in
China
involving a lot of work as a junior in
the clinics of senior doctors writing
case notes at that crowded table indeed
those junior clinicians still in the
course of their advanced medical
education are expected to take the day's
cases home and make their own copies of
symptom lists and prescription formulas
their clinical teachers encourage them
to analyze and reanalyze the logic of
each intervention to relive the
unwritten thought process by which an
experienced doctor found the root source
of a pattern and then designed a formula
structured to distinguish between the
most central aspects and those that are
more peripheral a Guangzhou Authority I
mentioned in my first lecture don't
airtel attempts of preliminary
introductions of the problem of tracing
down to the root in an essay but he even
he doesn't explain how to pull off the
magic trick of knowing for sure what the
route is this is a technical problem I'm
going to spare you the technical and
theoretical side of his discussion but
one of his examples might be helpful
especially for intellectuals like us who
are prone to headaches he begins his
explanation with this incurring illness
seek the route is a basic principle of
the discerning patterns and determining
therapies system according to which you
must seek out the basic reasons for
disease and advanced therapy on the
basis of your identification of the
illness essence and that he provides
this discussion of headache we can see
from this headache paragraph with its
list of patterns and it's parallel list
of treatment strategies that the route
being traced is not a structural
foundation of the disease it is not a
lesion it is not a population of
microbes that can be wiped out it is not
a localized trauma in your body rather
the root causes listed here are all
disease processes that have their
vicissitudes and involve much of the
person's body not just the head not just
now when the patient is in your clinic a
root is a functional source of disorder
which changes through
and must be caught in the act of causing
human misery the clinical imperative of
tracing down to the main root then is
inseparable from time considerations in
both pathology and therapeutics the
question of timing is evident in some
derived rules of thumb listed on this
slide the most important derived
principle donked at TAO explains is
called rudin branch urgent and slow
routine branch urgent and slow is a rule
of thumb that references the flexible
deployment of the principle of teaching
illness by seeking the route and then he
has three possibilities just looking at
the first of these three directives we
can see that knowing the difference
between root and branch phenomena is
really important
dung supplies an example to help us see
the urgency of keeping these things
properly sorted when it is urgent treat
the branch especially if the branch
phenomena are life-threatening or making
it impossible to treat the root for
example in a patient with liver disease
who is manifesting severe symptoms of
abdominal edema and distension shortness
of breath and no urination with
constipation you should first resolve
the branch phenomenon of abdominal
fluids cause urine and feces to pass
through reduce abdominal distension and
when the condition has stabilized then
you can treat the root which is the
liver system so we can see that these
medical images of roots and branches
arise from an experienced pragmatism of
the clinic even though these little
written lessons still don't tell our
young medical students how to be sure
they have grasped the essential nature
of the liver disease from which our
patient is suffering but I think they
gradually learn to see things from the
perspective of an experienced clinician
like Dante at all that is they know they
will have to make a distinction in each
case of illness they face between
essence and epiphenomenon
between primary and secondary problems
between roots and branches tracing the
route requires thought and as I've noted
above it demands that the infinity of
significant manifestations be limited or
be subjected to a sorting process in
which with that tradition
show us some reliable patterns moreover
the things recognized by medicine must
also become salient images we face only
as actionable situations the
transformations and the changes can
throw up a lot of strange images but the
images we face those these Dwight's
young you'll remember this term I'll go
back to it these days young that are
handy bye
and the patterns we recognize or cognos
are that subset of the possible that we
call the actual but let's look again at
dong tat house rule of thumb about roots
and branches in defining his principles
don't uses the term Ling Hwa which
usually means flexible and agile
responsive and efficacious this is a
word that is often used to describe the
talents of the most inspired and
respected doctors in traditional
medicine it is a beautiful word
combining wha a word for living with
Ling which perhaps most basically means
effective gods and spirits are Ling
after all if you present a need they
must respond the magic acts they pull
off for evidence of their Ling
effectiveness medicines are linked to
we've already seen that medicines
properly deployed can act like a god
perhaps this little adjective ling law
can be pushed to remind us that a good
doctor is magically lively an embodiment
of effective vitality buried in Dante
house rather dry and technical
explication of some essential clinical
rules of thumb then we find a nearly
religious attitude toward clinical
practice it can be done not only
properly but brilliantly magically if
you know how to trace symptomatic
experience down to its roots
now that Ling Hwa magical vitality has
brought us back to questions of practice
I want to start fulfilling some promises
I've been making in these lectures
promises that I have not yet kept most
obviously I haven't even broached the
topic of humanity announced in my title
for this lecture but I also haven't
finished with that other modern practice
theorists don't tell Peng who invited us
to cross the river by feeling for stones
so I want to return to groping our way
across the river
in our bare feet emotive practice to
which I'm attracted though I don't think
it can be done gracefully and then I
want to explain why I posted a title
like humanity as root think again about
crossing the river by feeling for stones
this pragmatic method of making progress
might be the only possible one under
present world circumstances and of
course dong Xiao ping the great leader
of the reform period thought that that
was the case but our metaphor is
reexamined allows us to ask why would
anyone want to cross the river in the
first place why is our practitioner
aiming to cross this stream to get to
that other side perhaps we should just
turn around and go home and forget all
metaphors that urges toward risky
practices tending toward barely visible
and possibly undesirable other Shores
all kinds of modern Chinese thinkers
have asked questions analogous to this
so let me abandon this increasingly
flawed metaphor and cut to the chase
there is a stubborn problem with all
pragmatic philosophies they seem to
offer no absolutist resources for a
correct ethics or a sound politics fully
aware that truth is collectively
constructed drowning in the
transformations and changes of a vast
natural way we are thrown back on
agnosticism about the nature of any one
shared world or one ethical rulebook how
can we direct our collective path I
think with this question I finally
gotten back to some very Terry lecture
religion and science dilemmas I want to
conclude then by turning again to Liu
guanxi in a Chinese medical authority
I've cited several times already he's
the one who chose to refer to medical
things as do I see on the image we face
in the 1995 preface to his collected
essays dr. Liu argues that medicine is
fundamentally humanistic to make this
argument the reference is philosophical
and clinical forebears as he makes his
way through the pragmatic and
relativistic waters of a medical
heritage that as I've tried to show is
far too rich to guide action in any
obvious and consensually agreed way
especially crucial for dr. Liu's
humanism is aligned from the very famous
early twentieth-century philologist in
revolutionary John Taeyang who few know
was also a physician and who wrote an
important book on modernizing Chinese
medicine John Tian said in 1929 the Dao
is not far from humanity the body of the
ill person is its greatest teacher Lu
gong since preface takes up this
fascinating and somewhat puzzling
observation and runs with it in his
conclusion to a section called if the
route is sound the way can come to life
he touches on many of the things and
thoughts I've been trying to put on our
agenda and here is a couple of
paragraphs that he wrote the self health
and self curing capacity of human life
generating Qi is the thing we serve and
the thing we study it is the thing
through which Chinese medicine
researchers must diligently become great
doctors of the masses she is that stuff
through which we may become touchstones
of genuine Chinese medicine if we depart
from this human life generating Qi this
route of life generation which must be
sought in the nurturing of life and in
the treatment of illness then we medical
people cannot expect any genuine Chinese
medicine to survive he goes on hence the
way of Chinese medicine advises the way
is not far from man let the body of the
person of the patient be your respected
teacher the root of Chinese medicines
way or Dao is the study of the human
learn from and with the things you serve
and he's thinking a patient's student
bodies here learn from and with the
things on which medicine relies such as
drugs and symptoms learn from and with
the things that develop medicine for
example scientific results historical
research learn from and with life
nurturance and disease treatment in
practice and seek development only out
of practice medicine at root is humanism
it would seem that Lou concludes here
with a non sequitur why is all this
engagement with things in practice like
bodies and drugs and books
so obviously humanistic to him the only
way to interpret this in his other
comments on taking the human as the root
is to realize that humans are ever and
always for him embodied understanding
the human situation he's saying can only
be a matter of knowing how embodiment
works through time as perhaps you
distinguished between root and branch
urgent and slow and in ecological
relations with specific life
environments Chinese medical people
often say we treat illness according to
the person the place and the moment
understanding of bodies though at least
in East Asia has always been most
salient to the aims of medicine that is
to say we know the patterns of embodied
life in order to act wholesomely to
improve human embodied life medicine
seeks to know and adjust the course of
the human in the great all-encompassing
way and Chinese medicine liu guanxi
knows is really good at that
so I want a really conclude of one less
polemical remark that gathers a number
of the threats I and my various Chinese
medical authorities have been weaving
together in these lectures and again
this is Luke Wang Sheng the proverb
medicine is thought the proverb medicine
is thought reflection on and by human
beings is a practical concept that
applies thought to the character of
things Chinese medicine is an opening
investigate the border between heaven
and the human penetrate the difference
between illness and health accord with
the way of life giving birth to life
then heaven and the human cannot but
join their powers for the better this is
the effect
practical wisdom of a wholesome cosmos
in which life ceaselessly gives birth to
more life this is the Dow of Medicine
and it is here on this simultaneously
natural and ethical terrain that we can
see how an East Asian science after all
this technical material after all this
technical material I think we can call
Chinese medicine of science this East
Asian science joins it's unique powers
for knowing the patterns of human life
and human suffering with the virtues of
the myriad things that make up the vast
flow of the spontaneous cosmic way for
me for a long time now Chinese medicine
has been an opening to a new and
different world of things thoughts and
actions it has allowed me to hear deep
things talked about that has had me
struggling to understand it has required
close attention to translation it has
been an invitation to understand
knowledge as a practice I hope these
lectures have been a way of sharing with
you that problematic thrill that way of
feeling the presence of the vastness of
unfamiliar worlds
[Applause]
thank you Judy we have time for
questions and let me ask you to come to
the mics we need you to come to the mics
not just for amplification but because
we're recording this and so we need you
to relax for questions and please make
your questions as brief as possible and
make them actually questions
I was wondering how how do Chinese
medics see Western medicine what's their
take on the Westerners well they
understand a lot more about Western
medicine and Western medical doctors
understand about Chinese medicine you
know and they and many Chinese today
many Chinese doctors are well trained in
Western met biomedical primary care and
various biomedical specialties
many of them use sonograms and x-ray
images they can read lab results you
know they're perfectly willing to
incorporate the technologies and logics
of biomedicine into their practice and
there are many various ways of doing
that
there are some people who are more
purist as I've argued the last couple of
times but Chinese medical doctors
Chinese medical writers and teachers in
the PRC today are also aware that they
are kind of they have to defend
themselves against attacks from
biomedical interests that argue that
they're operating a pseudoscience so
there there is tension between the
fields but there's also constant in
every clinic many complex combinations
of the fields does that answer your
question ok thank you let me ask you to
identify yourself when you ask your
question so Shoji will know maybe where
you're coming from a bit hi I'm Bonnie
Kaplan and I'm part of several programs
here including the bioethics Center I'm
curious about two ways two aspects of
Western medicine and how they would
compare with the thinking that you've
been explicating about Chinese medicine
one is how our preventive medicine
things thought about you talked a lot
about people's discomforts and symptoms
and illnesses or is there a practice of
preventive medicine as we think of
preventive medicine where you don't have
to be sick yet
answer that question first and then
we'll let you ask your other question
okay so there's an ancient saying from
the wand engaging the yellow Emperor's
inner Canon which is the first century
Bible of traditional Chinese medicine
and that is the highest doctor clear
cures the not yet sick right so and and
there is a very deep and long tradition
not entirely continuous I think but
nevertheless it's been there in the
literature for a long time of life
nurturing technologies techniques which
are about staying healthy and there's a
huge fad in China now in the last couple
decades to mobilize these life nurturing
techniques in efforts to remain healthy
so preventive medicine has opened and
all the Chinese medical politico's and
polemicists have insisted since the 50s
when they started to really totally
institutionalize that preventive
medicine is central to Chinese medicine
and actually you can see it in a
different way too is the Chinese
medicine deals with so many subtle
symptoms that you you can't you don't go
to a doctor for them you feel a little
bit subpar you're tired all the time you
have you've been bothered by bad dreams
you can you can get help from a Chinese
doctor which is a way of preventing any
worsening of your condition so that this
may be preventive medicine is a kind of
a continuum which is very much available
in China but mostly under the aegis of
traditional Chinese medicine I think
although of course public health
departments are busy doing public health
education to prevent chronic illnesses
if the other question thank you for that
explanation the other question had to do
with ways of thinking
about medicine and health in the Western
world before we had the kinds of
technologies that enabled you to do more
of what we consider interior diagnostic
work seeing inside the body so how would
this compare with previous practices of
medicine that we now consider oh those
are no good they're ineffective but well
but in terms of ways of thinking like
humoral Theory ethers their humors and
so forth it's not my field I haven't
done any research on this and so I don't
like to just you know engage in loose
talk about it
but it's much easier to compare Chinese
medical logics and Chinese medical
thinking with medicine from before 1850
in Europe and America I think thank you
I think hi Tim thank you thank you thank
you my name is Tim I'm a practitioner he
actually does this stuff folks yeah I
was wondering the image of the doctor
with the patient and you observing that
I was wondering what role you think
faith has hey outcomes ha lots of people
think that a doctor-patient relationship
when it's really working well it's young
fun it's fate right faith faith faith
remaining I think faith in it's a it's a
classic medical anthropology term faith
in the healer I think it's important for
Chinese medicine it's important for
biomedicine it's important for every
kind of healing right and it's also not
required for Chinese medicine to work so
there's there there are some some people
and not so much now but you know in
maybe an earlier generation we're
writing about the traditional medicines
of various places and taking what I
called the psychological detour they
couldn't account for why these medicines
were popular and considered to be
effective in the places where they were
Ayurveda Chinese medicine various kinds
of
shamanic healing and so forth they
couldn't account for why they were
helped to be effective and so they would
take the psychological detour and say
well the patient must just have a very
strong belief and therefore a placebo
effect kicks in and the patient recovers
but you know from doing acupuncture I
know from observing so much herbal
medicine and taking herbal medicine
myself faith doesn't have to be there
for it to work Mary Ellen Tucker
Forestry and divinity and religious
studies I wanted to just draw you out
and thank you for this lecture you might
have mentioned this in your other ones
but one of the differences clearly if
modern Western science is the individual
rather than the context and I wanted to
just draw you out in terms of the
organic and holistic sensibilities that
we talked about of needham and so on
that the assumption here is that the
healing has to take place in relation to
the Chi of the world that she around one
well you heard that in some of the
things that I was sharing here today but
but it's an issue because I think that
modern TCM has individualized in order
to persuade the world that it too is a
medicine now we have this very ancient
remark and in the West medicine is the
science of the individual and there is
no science of the individual right and
Chinese medicine as it modernized as it
institutionalized as these writers had
to defend their craft and their skills
against biomedical modernizers they
gradually evolved the field toward more
of an individual discrete body kind of
practice so that whole ism as it's used
in a lot of Chinese medicine today is
about a whole ism of the body that is if
I have a symptom in my ear it's
undoubtedly related to symptoms that
might be as remote as my feet or fingers
right however that's that's one kind of
whole
another kind of holism is Tara Hawaii
heaven and man joined as one and a lot
of theorists and philosophers of Chinese
medicine like to end up their arguments
with ten raha ye but that it's a little
bit of a stretch if they're talking
about the way medicine is worked today
but okay apart from what you've just
said about the modern context the
references in the text and so on are
about the changes the subtle changes and
some of the transform changes and
transformations yeah so the transforming
and nourishing powers of heaven and
earth that the doctrine of the mean
speaks about and so on and that so my
question here would go to that this the
object is still to have a sense of
harmony right with with the natural
world as the healing part of the healing
component or at least collusion
collaboration you know being able to get
on together you know but it is it it
doesn't really it that's why I think the
ten rahowa logic that we get from some
polemicists today it doesn't leave me
entirely satisfied because it divides
the human from the natural in a very
modernist formation the way it's mostly
interpreted and that's not the Dow
that's not as you know perfectly well
that's not the way it was divided up in
pre-modern writing other question right
if you want to add just one more
certainty okay so the the Dow though or
the context this larger context is in a
Confucian in Taoist sense especially
Confucian moral and this the sense that
this the powers that are there are not
separated from the individual as the
healing component so this non-dual
sensibility that we talked about is I
think a huge
rich contribution of traditional Chinese
medicine it is and and that kind of
unity of experience unity of process
which the doctors classic sources are
training him to see and know mm-hmm that
that's that's a little bit too much
everything is everything for the working
doctor so looking to you know following
my program here and looking back at
knowledge from the pragmatics of action
he has to sort right and he has to sort
in a way that he can act on to help this
patient who has come into his modern
clinic right so he's not going to be
engaging in a cosmology he's not going
to be privileged in a cosmology in which
the human is only one of the ten
thousand things and in which there's
instead he's going to be privileged in a
cosmology which I really think is
modernist and not so much there in the
classic sources in which you have human
and the human is in their context humans
in their environment and you can spend a
lot of time worrying about what's the
relationship between them but it's a
modernist problem
I feel thank you Mary
hi I'm Valerie Hansen from the history
department I love the quote from William
James and I was wondering if you might
be tempted to translate the word Qi into
English I have never been tempted to do
this are you tensed but would you
translate it there have been there have
been a lot of translations actually I
was just looking at your book and there
are quite a few and Mary Evelyn spoke I
recommend it to you subscribe to the
victor Mayer School of writing for the
world which is if you're writing for the
world do you and in English then you
don't leave words in Chinese so so yeah
I I don't know I'm so tempted to go with
experience that's unlike you to be a
little too compassion and
I like using chi in English sentences
and I do it all the time with students
and in my own writing and so forth of
course we all have to explain Chi and
I'm always providing some kind of a
definition or explanation every time I
have it in any sustained work but so can
i I'd like that
pardon me could I ask you for that I'm
sorry I missed lectures warning Oh what
the explanation yeah well I most often
rely on Nathan savants very simplistic
one she is the stuff that makes things
happen and the stuff in which things
happen sounds contradictory but that's
the problem with defining it as a thing
she is a process she is a kind of it's
it's a it's a moment in in the changes
and the transformations and so to try to
define it as a noun with a fixed stable
reference is a mistake and that's why
the translation is always problematic in
my answer to all these kinds of
questions as always
are you working from ancient Greek Latin
and Hebrew is you just keep translating
you just always translating and you
never stop translating with different
translations and then because you can't
settle it right no you can't settle it
and so you can try to you can try
different things and of course I I don't
you know there are plenty of sentences
that Luke walks in might write that have
the word Chi in them that I might not
use the word Chi in my translation in
order to say exactly what I think he's
saying but she is so contextual you know
it just means something so there's in
fact there's a fascinating article in
one of the 1980s journals of Chinese
medicine written at a time when a great
many intellectuals in the world of
Chinese medicine we're trying to settle
some big theoretical issues collectively
for the whole field and this is a much
cited article on the nature of cheek and
it basically says she is configurative
force or she is always configured
there's a myriad forms of chief so there
is
there is no experience of unitary
monistic t she is not a monad right but
it is the the energies of the myriad
things in their all their myriad
differences and they say for medicine T
is the function of bodily systems so the
five visceral systems you can say the
Chi of the liver is its functions and
that there were many many sentences
written in Chinese that are a framed
that way so they had to make a
distinction between Chi as a stuff that
is happening in the world right and she
as a figure of speech which is talking
about happening in a particular way okay
we have time for one more question so
I'm gonna move to you yes so hello my
name is Tonya and I just finished
medical school and I'm in public health
and my question is what would your
response be to healthcare professionals
who kind of want to know more about like
the research evidence for acupuncture or
other Chinese medicine practices and
kind of how do you approach
conversations like that oh there are
tons of journals Tim could tell you
right there are lots and lots of
journals of clinical research and bench
research on various aspects of Chinese
medicine and herbal medicine and
acupuncture it's all and in my reading I
just something just came into my inbox
yesterday the Journal of Integrative
Medicine do you get that you see that
it's it's all very very very very
restricted projects one plant one
substance one needling technique and a
big clinical trial trying to evaluate it
and for me that's great I'm glad it's
happening
doesn't help me at all but if you really
want it to be a complementary and
alternative medicine public health
public servant you know you could get
those journals and you could study at
all and maybe
you could get somewhere with it I don't
know thank you I would like to remind
you there's a lovely reception with good
wine and food following this in this
same building please journey over to the
reception we want to thank the Terry
lectures committee and the office of the
vice president and secretary for
supplying all of this and one more time
let us thank Judith Farquhar
[Music]